[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
in allen einen guten Dienstagabend der
ein historischer Tag ist für die USA das
muss man so sagen dennoch nie zuvor in
der Geschichte musste sich ein früherer
Präsident einem Strafverfahren stellen
ein früherer Präsident der seine
Anhänger bereits zu Protesten auffordert
und der selbst sagt der Richter hasse
ihn Donald Trump vor Gericht in New York
angeklagt in 34 Fällen
Geschäftsunterlagen verfälscht zu haben
und wie damals als er noch Präsident war
ein ganzes Land schaut zu die einen
begeistert die anderen beunruhigt der
Bürgermeister fürchtet Ausschreitungen
und warnt unsere Botschaft ist klar
kontrollieren Sie sich elmatismus
Trump oder Tod steht da man kann das
getrost wohl Zirkus nennen oder erster
Akt des Drama seine Angeklagter
Ex-Präsident ist ja eine ernste Sache
für den Rechtsstaat aber seine Fans
fühlen sich und ihr Idol zu Unrecht
angegriffen
der Staatsanwalt will Trump ins
Gefängnis stecken gleichzeitig aber
lässt der täglich kriminelle laufen
sie tun alles um ihn zu stoppen aber er
wird nicht aufgeben und wir auch nicht
mitten im Getümmel auch republikanischer
Abgeordnete George Santos und majory
Taylor green beide nicht für ihren Hang
zur Wahrheit bekannt sondern für ihren
Drang Stimmung zu machen
die Demokraten sind Kommunisten die
Amerika und die Freiheit zerstören auch
der zweite Akt des Schauspiels ein
Spektakel keinen Zentimeter fährt Trumps
Konvoi unbeobachtet zum Gericht maximal
öffentlich die Anklagepunkte da noch
geheim er soll schweige Geld für
Erotikdarstellerin stormy Daniels
fälschlicherweise als Anwaltskosten
verbucht haben um im Wahlkampf 2016 eine
alte Affäre zu vertuschen wie jeder
andere mutmaßliche Straftäter musste er
jetzt seine Fingerabdrücke drinnen
abgeben auf ein Foto haben sie wohl
verzichtet aber er war nun offiziell
verhaftet als er kurz vor halb drei
Hochzeit zum Richter ging
dann der dritte Akt mit versteinertem
Gesicht erfährt der Angeklagte der
morgens noch eifrig den Richter
beschimpft hatte von den 34
Anklagepunkten wegen Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen und Verstoßes gegen
das Wahlgesetz nicht nur im Fall stormy
Daniels sondern auch bei einer zweiten
schweigegeldzahlung an eine weitere Frau
er plädiert auf nicht schuldig
dass er nicht über dem Gesetz steht das
ist für sie das Signal des Tages ob es
am Ende für eine Verurteilung reicht ist
völlig offen
er musste zum ersten Mal in seinem Leben
vor dem Richter stehen und er hat viel
Schlechtes gemacht
er sollte lebenslänglich ins Gefängnis
er ist eine gefährliche Person und eine
Bedrohung für die Demokratie
bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt alles friedlich
Menschen üben ihr Recht auf
Meinungsfreiheit aus und der Rechtsstaat
oder seinem Anspruch wohl gerecht
ja wir haben gerade noch mal gesehen die
US-Fernsehsender zeigen seit Stunden
jede noch so belanglose Bewegung von
Donald Trump live gerne auch aus dem
Hubschrauber Johannes Hanau ist für uns
live in New York guten Abend Johannes
wie hat man sich denn diese Atmosphäre
vorzustellen aktuell vor dem
Gerichtsgebäude in New York
also es ist vor allen Dingen eine
unglaubliche medienauflauf hier es ist
sehr viel mehr Journalisten und
Journalisten hier unterwegs als
Demonstranten es war ja angekündigt dass
es möglicherweise zu größeren Protesten
kommt insgesamt waren es aber vielleicht
nur so zwei 300 Demonstranten die hier
waren pro Trump und anti Trump die
wurden mit abspeckgittern voneinander
getrennt das ganze lief ziemlich
friedlich ab die Polizei wird dir die
ganze Zeit sehr entspannt das sieht
nicht so aus als würde die irgendwas
noch anbrennen diese Anklage Eröffnung
dann tatsächlich im Gerichtsgebäude hat
aber deutlich länger gedauert als
eigentlich geplant warum denn
also was wir hören ist dass der
Staatsanwalt wohl große Bedenken hatte
von Trumps über Trumps hastriarden die
er gegen den Richter losgelassen hat
aber er hat ja in der Vergangenheit auch
ein Foto von sich gepostet mit dem
Baseballschläger in der Hand und dem
Staatsanwalt daneben das sieht man als
Gewalt Aufruf und der Sohn von Donald
Trump hat ein Foto der Tochter des
Richters gerade gepostet und der Richter
hat gesagt also das sei sehr bedenklich
was er da macht und er hat Trump wohl
keinen Maulkorb Verlass gegeben das
heißt ihm verboten komplett per Gericht
verbieten lassen dass er weiter zur Hass
aufrufen darf und auch zu Gewalt er hat
ihm aber klar gemacht dass er das nicht
dulden wird sollte er das weitermachen
und dann müssen wir jetzt mal schauen ob
sich Donald Trump daran halten wird nach
dem Gerichtstermin heute Johannes wird
dann Trump erstmal zurück nach malago in
Florida fliegen wie geht's denn
juristisch weiter wir müssen ja alle
einen wirklich sehr sehr langen Atem
haben und Monaten denken oder
das glaube ich auch also die Tatsache es
wird jetzt erstmal verschiedene Motion
Studis Miss geben das heißt also
Niederlegung des Verfahrens seitens der
Anwälte und dann wird eine Jury
ausgesucht sollten das nicht stattfinden
dann gibt es eine Jury das wird ungefähr
zwei drei vier Wochen dauern das ganze
dauert also bestimmt bis in den Sommer
bevor ihr überhaupt der erste Anklage
oder der erste Verhandlungstag
stattfinden wird es gibt zum ersten
Nachrichten die sagen es geht noch bis
Anfang 2024 oder sogar Frühling 2024 bis
es dann weitergeht Johannes erstmal ganz
herzlichen Dank für diese aktuellen
Nachrichten aus New York vor dem
Gerichtsgebäude
Volker deppert ist Professor für Amerika
Studien an der Uni Regensburg ein
Amerika Historiker und einer der in El
Paso Texas geboren ist und uns jetzt
diese große dieses große wundersame Land
erklärt Herr Professor guten Abend
guten Abend was wird denn mal bleiben
von diesem Tag ist das jetzt der Anfang
einer geordneten juristischen
Aufarbeitung oder weiterer Höhe bzw
Tiefpunkt eines perspektakels
ich glaube dass es Ausweis der
Polarisierung des Landes ist dass man
nicht so genau sagen kann was aus diesem
Prozess jetzt entsteht das ist
historisch präzedenzlos noch nie ist ein
ehemaliger Präsident vor Gericht
angeklagt worden und er wird jetzt auch
nicht als Präsident angeklagt sondern
als Privatmann die ihm vorgeworfenen
Vergehen sind Wirtschaftskriminelle Art
das geht also noch nicht mal irgendwie
um Amtsmissbrauch und wir sehen ja an
dem an den Aufläufen in New York es gibt
Trump Befürworter es gibt die Trump
Gegner und man kann wirklich nicht so
ganz sagen was in welche Richtung sich
die ganze Sache jetzt entwickelt fühlen
Sie sich so ein bisschen als Amerika
Historiker an Al Capone erinnert den man
ja weiland auch nur wir
Steuerhinterziehung beikam letztlich
oder oder bleibt da ein komischer
Beigeschmack dass die Justiz Trump jetzt
wegen einer im Vergleich was ihm noch
alles vorgeworfen wird doch einer
Lappalie verfolgt
ja sie sagen es richtig also es sind
eher geringfügige vergehen die ihm jetzt
hier vorgeworfen waren es laufen wir
gleichzeitig Ermittlungen gegen ihn im
Staate Georgia wegen direkter
Wahlfälschung es gibt auch eine
bundesermittlung gegen ihn auf der Basis
des Untersuchungsberichts des
kongressausschusses der im Dezember ja
veröffentlicht worden ist da stehen also
ganz andere Vorwürfe im Raum die
wirklich Kapitalverbrechen
höchste Art sind insofern ist das jetzt
hier vielleicht der Auftakt einer
prozess-serie die also immer höhere und
immer schwerwiegende Vorwürfe erreicht
auf der anderen Seite habe ich nach wie
vor den Eindruck dass die Gerichte in
den USA zum einen weiterhin
funktionieren was man auch daran sehen
kann dass ja keine seiner Klagen gegen
Wahlfälschungen in den Einzelstaaten
irgendwie durchgekommen ist selbst in
den Staaten die mehrheitlich
republikanisch gewählt haben auch die
Verbrecher oder die redeführer des 6
Januar sind ja nach dem Recht und Gesetz
der USA verurteilt war insofern die
Gerichte scheinen noch zu funktionieren
sie werden nach meinem Eindruck auch
immer noch als ein Medium der
Wahrheitsfindung in der amerikanischen
Gesellschaft gesehen ich meine man denkt
an all die gerichtsfilme aus Hollywood
wo ja das Gericht dann doch immer der
Ort ist an dem Wahrheit dann doch
gefunden wird also es kann sein dass ich
das durchsetzt es kann aber auch sein
dass jetzt eben selbst die Gerichte als
die letzte noch integere Institution der
amerikanischen Demokratie auch in diese
polarisierungsdynamik reinkommen und
eben auch nur noch als parteiisch
gesehen werden und woran liegt und dann
muss man sich wirklich Sorgen machen auf
jeden Fall aber woran liegt das wie es
jetzt weitergeht hängt das jetzt alles
am Richter der wie manche sagen alles
richtig machen muss wirklich alles
richtig machen muss oder wie groß ist
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass am Ende alle
Amerikaner ein Urteil das Urteil
akzeptieren
man muss auf jeden Fall sehen dass das
sich nicht so einfach einsortieren lässt
in die Demokraten gegen die Republikaner
es ist ein Geschworenen Gericht ihm
sitzen Geschworene gegenüber die als aus
der Mitte der Gesellschaft kommen die
auch einen Spiegelbild der Gesellschaft
sein sollen und es gibt klar definierte
juristische Verfahren der Beweisführung
der Entscheidungsfindung und je klarer
ihre regelkonforme und ihr transparenter
dieses Verfahren läuft desto schwerer
wird es für Trump und sein Lager auf
Dauer dieses narrativ der Hexenjagd
durchzuhalten eine Frage müssen wir auf
jeden Fall noch besprechen Herr
Professor heute Abend hier Donald Trump
will ja noch mal Präsident werden kann
man schon sagen was dieser Prozess und
das ganze Drumherum für seine Chancen
bedeutet
naja das formal spricht jetzt erstmal
nichts dagegen dass selbst ein
verurteilter Mensch noch mal sich um das
Präsidentenamt bewirbt es hängt hier
jetzt glaube ich sehr stark von
Zeitplänen ab wir haben ja schon gehört
das kann noch Monate dauern bis dieses
Verfahren überhaupt beginnt heute ist ja
erstmal nur die Anklage beschlossen
worden und die Anklageschrift verlesen
worden wenn dieses Verfahren in den
Vorwahl kämpfen die ja dann im nächsten
Jahr beginnen werden dann ständig neue
Schlagzeilen produziert kann das sich
auf die Wahlchancen auswirken und ich
glaube ja immer noch dass es ein
Großteil von Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikanern gibt die
entlang von law and order denken die
also vielleicht jetzt eben politisch
polarisiert sind die aber dann doch
immer noch die Urteile der Gerichte
anerkennen sofern sie denn auf
regelkonformen und transparenter Weise
zustande gekommen sind und das kann sich
dann schon auch noch gegen Trump richten
aber wie gesagt die Zukunft ist offen
und es kann in beide Richtungen gehen
sagt er Amerika ist zurücker Volker
depper Professor an der Uni Regensburg
Herr Professor vielen Dank
vielen Dank auch ihn
so viel zunächst zu diesem Thema heute
abend es ist heute so ziemlich das
Gegenteil von dem eingetreten was
Wladimir Putin erreichen wollte statt
die NATO zu schwächen hat er sie
gestärkt
Finnland das eine 1.300 km lange
Ostgrenze mit Russland teilt und die
Erinnerung an zwei Kriege mit der
Sowjetunion ist seit heute Nachmittag
offiziell Teil des westlichen
Verteidigungsbündnisses das Land im
hohen Norden sucht Schutz bei der NATO
aufgeschreckt von dem was der Ukraine
widerfahren ist
Finnland bringt auch viel mit für die
NATO es ist ein Tag der mal in den
Geschichtsbüchern stehen wird aber
während sie in Helsinki und Brüssel
feiern wächst in Stockholm die Ungeduld
der schwedische Beitritt zum Bündnis ist
weiter blockiert Florian neu hat mit mir
manchmal sieht Geschichte ziemlich
bescheiden aus um 14:45 Uhr tauschen
drei Herren in Brüssel Mappen aus die
formelle Einladung an Finnland und die
formelle Zusage Finnlands an die USA
mit dem Empfang dieses Dokuments
erklären wir Finnland zum 31 Mitglied
der NATO
am 4 april 1949 hatte sich die NATO in
Washington gegründet als
Verteidigungsbündnis des Westens damals
mit 12 Staaten genau 74 Jahre später
wird vor dem NATO-Hauptquartier in
Brüssel fahren eine Nummer 31 gehisst
vor kurzem hätte damit niemand gerechnet
doch dann kam der Krieg
[Musik]
als Russland im vergangenen Jahr die
Ukraine Angriff da habe ich wie wohl die
Mehrheit der Finnen gedacht was der
Ukraine passieren kann das kann uns auch
passieren
dieser Beitritt ist eine Sache für die
wie Herrn Putin danken können er führte
etwas herbei was er verhindern wollte
Finnland bringt einiges mit in die NATO
etwa eine Luftwaffe die die vieler
westeuropäischer Mitgliedsländer in den
Schatten stellt
ist jetzt stärker mit Finnland als
Mitglied ihre Streitkräfte sind stark
und äußerst fähig an Heilig für viele
aber fühlt sich dieses Gruppenbild heute
unvollständig an Schweden wollte
gemeinsam mit Finnland beitreten doch
dem Land fehlt das endgültige ok aus
Ungarn und der Türkei und der
schwedische Außenminister geht an die
Grenzen der diplomatischen Höflichkeit
es gibt wieder für das ungarische noch
für das türkische Parlament einen Grund
zu warten sie sollten unseren Beitritt
jetzt ratifizieren
das werde bald klappen so spricht man
ihm und sich in der NATO heute Mut zu
ihm dagegen dem ukrainischen
Außenminister die Metro kolleper will
oder kann so etwas heute keiner Zusagen
ein schneller Beitritt der Ukraine wie
von Kollegah gefordert das ist für die
NATO mitten im Krieg kein Thema
und so wird hier am Abend nur eine
zusätzliche Flagge die finde ich schon
was der Kreml in Moskau als weitere
Bedrohung bezeichnet und nicht nur
Finnland dagegen als Beginn einer neuen
Ära der Sicherheit
wir hatten auch mal diskutiert ob wir so
wie ihr in Deutschland unsere
Landesverteidigung abbauen sollten hat
uns der kommandierende der finnischen
Streitkräfte vor ein paar Wochen hier im
heute-journal gesagt aber wir waren klug
genug das nicht zu tun und das zahlt
sich jetzt aus der General wirkte dabei
weder überheblich noch schadenfroh
sondern einfach nur erleichtert
und wir bleiben noch bei der großen
Sorgen bereitenden Weltlage Europa
schickt zwei Abgesandte nach China die
Präsidentin der EU-Kommission und den
Präsidenten Frankreichs die beiden
sollen in Peking ein Signal europäischer
Geschlossenheit setzen obwohl Europas
China Strategie alles andere als
geschlossen ist die Pole sind kaum noch
miteinander zu vereinen China bleibt
unverzichtbare Handelspartner und wird
immer mehr zum politischen Gegner was
Europa aus chinesischer Sicht ist
beschreibt jetzt Miriam Steiner
das Wetter passt zu Kulisse es ist ein
Stück Europa am Stadtrand von Peking der
alte Sommerpalast Kaiser Residenz
während der Team Dynastie erbaut nach
europäischem Vorbild das ist was übrig
blieb nachdem die Europäer in
niederbrannten wie steht es heute um das
Verhältnis zwischen China und Europa
viele Dinge die wir heute benutzen sind
made in Germany sie brauchen unseren
Markt wie ihre Technik
so viele Konflikte sind nicht nötig
schön wenn jeder einfach Geld verdienen
kann
einer der Konflikte liegt hier in der
mit Kaviar zelebrierten Freundschaft wie
sehr die das Verhältnis zu Europa
belastet ist in pekingsführung immer
noch nicht angekommen China selbst
bezeichnet sich als Freund von Russland
und der Ukraine als neutralen Vermittler
die Bilder vermitteln was anderes
Staatsschauspiel den Ping reist nach
Moskau während europäische Vertreter
sich in Kiew auf die Klinke in die Hand
geben Europas Reaktion auf Putins Krieg
überraschte Peking wie eng der Westen
zusammenrückte und das Europa bereit
sein würde massive wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten in Kauf zu nehmen und da
reden wir von
Verdoppelung des Gaspreises für
individualhaushalte dass die EU das in
Kauf nehmen würde das hat man in Peking
ganz sicher nicht erwartet
Peking profitiert von den Lücken die der
Westen hinterlässt kauft russisches Gas
und Öl günstig ein will mit Partnern wie
Brasilien Indien und Südafrika ein
Gegengewicht zum besten aufbauen baut
mit den neuen Seidenstraße weltweite
Handelsrouten und nutzt seine
Wirtschaftsmacht für die Lieblings Ziel
bis 2049 weltweit Nummer eins sein
bis dahin braucht China Europa seinen
größten Handelspartner als Absatzmarkt
und als Lieferant von Geld und wissen
vor allem bei Technologie und Hightech
genau das sieht Europa kritisch auf die
Ankündigung von Kommissionspräsidenten
Ursula von der Leyen unabhängiger werden
zu wollen reagiert Peking wie üblich
wir hoffen dass Sie bei Ihrem Besuch in
China und in ihrem Dialog mit der
chinesischen Führung in der Lage sein
wird China besser zu verstehen
wenn sie diese Woche gemeinsam mit dem
französischen Präsidenten nach Peking
kommt wird hoffentlich nicht nur die
Stimmung am alten Kaiserpalast besser
sondern auch das Wetter
so jetzt ein erster Blick auf die
Nachrichtenübersicht heute mit dir Hanna
ja Ende März hatte Russland angekündigt
taktische Atomwaffen nach Belarus zu
verlegen heute bestätigte der russische
Verteidigungsminister Scholl gudy
Übergabe eines raketensystems vom Typ
ist kann da M Bella russische Kampfjets
hätten nun die Möglichkeit erhalten mit
atomar ausgestatteten
Vernichtungsmitteln Schläge gegen
feindobjekte zu führen sagte Scheu gut
zudem habe die Ausbildung belarussischer
Soldaten an dem russischen Raketensystem
begonnen
an Tag 2 seines Besuchs in der Ukraine
hat Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck
mit dem ukrainischen Energieminister
hallo chenko vereinbart die
Energiepartnerschaft zwischen den beiden
Ländern auszubauen so will Deutschland
hier beim Wiederaufbau des ukrainischen
Energiesystems helfen mit dem Ziel ist
außerdem klimafreundlicher zu gestalten
in Brüssel sind bei einer Razzia die
Geschäftsräume der Europäischen
Volkspartei durchsucht worden
Hintergrund sind Ermittlungen der
Staatsanwaltschaft Erfurt gegen den
Thüringer cdu-partei und Fraktionschef
Mario Vogt konkret geht es um den
Verdacht der Bestechlichkeit während des
europawahlkampfs 2019 Vogt hat die
Vorwürfe zurückgewiesen
der Initiator der querdenkenbewegung
Michael Ballweg wurde unter Auflagen aus
der Untersuchungshaft entlassen laut
Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart sei der
Fluchtanreiz nicht mehr so hoch wie im
vergangenen Juni als er inhaftiert
worden war die Staatsanwaltschaft
Stuttgart hat Ballweg wegen versuchten
Betrugs Geldwäsche und Steuerstraftaten
angeklagt ihm wird unter anderem
vorgeworfen mehr als 9000 Spender über
die Verwendung von rund einer Million
Euro getäuscht zu haben ungefähr die
Hälfte soll er privat genutzt haben
weilwegs Anwalt bestreitet die Vorwürfe
in den Niederlanden ist bei einem
Zugunglück ein Mensch ums Leben gekommen
30 Personen wurden zum Teil schwer
verletzt am Morgen waren in der Nähe von
Den Haag ein Intercity und ein Güterzug
auf einen Baukran aufgefahren denn das
sieht die entgleiste in ein Feld zum
Zeitpunkt des Unfalls wurden auf der
Strecke Wartungsarbeiten durchgeführt
deshalb waren zwei der vier Gleise
gesperrt die Unglücksursache ist noch
unklar
das wohl letzte Aktionärs Treffen einer
einst stolzen Großbank war heute in
Zürich zu erleben und ein heftig
gebeutelter Aktionär der
zusammengebrochenen credit-suisse wird
dort so zitiert ich fühle mich wie man
auf Schweizerdeutsch sagt beschissen
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob man das
auf Schweizerdeutsch wirklich so sagt
aber der Frust ist verständlich denn
ausgerechnet die Schweiz die sich so
gerne für Ihre grundsolide Art rühmt hat
ja plötzlich zu notgesetzen gegriffen um
die einstige Säule des Finanzplatzes
Zürich zu retten das war ein Notverkauf
in letzter Sekunde der viele ihre
Einlagen gekostet hat und das Schweizer
Bankensystem viel Vertrauen Anna gehört
und an die Linke
167 Jahre gab es die Kredit Suisse nun
fand heute die letzte Hauptversammlung
statt für die Aktionäre bleibt nur ein
Bruchteil des früheren aktienwertes in
Form von Anteilen am neuen Eigentümer
der UBS Bank
ich habe Mitarbeiter bekommen weil ich
lange gearbeitet habe und dass ich jetzt
alles so
und es tut sehr weh also sehr bedrückend
und schlecht natürlich also man hat sich
das äh komplett anders vorgestellt als
Aktionär vor gut zwei Wochen mussten der
Schweizer Staat und Konkurrent obs die
Kredit Swiss wurde Pleite retten immer
mehr Anleger hatten ihr Geld abgezogen
am Ende ging es ganz schnell an einem
Wochenende
dass wir den über Jahre hinweg
aufgestauten Vertrauensverlust nicht
mehr aufhalten konnten dass wir sie alle
enttäuscht haben
dafür bitte ich um Entschuldigung
Finanzmarktexperten waren von der
Entwicklung nicht überrascht seit 15
Jahren wissen wir dass die großen Banken
unterkapitalisiert sind und nicht nur in
der Schweiz dass sie undurchsichtig sind
dass sie Anreiz haben
Risiken einzugehen auf Kosten des
Steuerzahlers und trotzdem hat man
gewartet ein Vorwurf der auch der FINMA
gilt der schweizerischen
Finanzmarktkontrolle hat sie eine Kultur
von Egoismus und kurzfrist denken
zugelassen konnte und wollte sie nicht
Härte gegen die Kredits des vorgehen
S hat Maßnahmen ergriffen wir haben
Maßnahmen angeordnet und die Bank hat
sie auch umgesetzt die Probleme sind
aber einfach immer wieder hochgekommen
in verschiedenen Bereichen
ihre Strategie ihren Risiko Appetit und
ihre Risikokultur
hierfür soll er ab morgen zuständig sein
Sergio Morty der neue Chef der UBS die
Stelle hatte er vor gut zehn Jahren
schon inne führte die UBS aus der
Finanzkrise er Beschnitt das
Investmentbanking kürzte Personal
steuerte das Risiko die UBS hat eine
ganz schwierige Situation man hat jetzt
sich selbst saniert man hat sich gut
aufgestellt man macht ordentliche
Gewinne und jetzt kriegt man die ganzen
Probleme des Konkurrenten auf den Tisch
der das alles offenkundig nicht getan
hat und jetzt muss man von vorne
anfangen und dabei werden die Risiko
Summen für die Schweiz und den
Steuerzahler gewiss nicht kleiner mit
der nun gigantischen UBS
das credit Swiss Management hat sich
heute wortreich entschuldigt und
gleichzeitig was Fehler angeht mit dem
Finger konsequent auf andere gezeigt
manches ändert sich nie in der Schweizer
Bankenwelt
so Hannah du machst jetzt weiter mit
einer anderen Bank
und Thema das Bundeskanzler Scholz schon
lange begleitet es geht um den
Steuerskandal rund um die Warburg Bank
und Scholz Rolle dabei damals als
Hamburger Bürgermeister die
Unionsfraktion im Bundestag hat nun
angekündigt dass sie einen
Untersuchungsausschuss dazu einsetzen
will Frank Bethmann was soll dieser
jetzt genau klären es geht um die Frage
welchen möglichen Einfluss stolz
genommen hat damit die Warburg Bank eben
keine Millionen schweren Rückzahlungen
an den Fiskus leisten musste bei den
Rückzahlungen sprechen wir im Übrigen
über Steuererstattungen die die Bank zu
Unrecht erhalten hatte und damals noch
nicht einmal zurückzahlen musste warum
wurde das Geldhaus davor bewahrt es geht
darum ob von der Politik möglicherweise
von Olaf Scholz selbst Einfluss auf
Hamburger Behörden genommen wurde und ob
die bisherigen Aussagen von Olaf Scholz
zu seiner Rolle glaubhaft sind Scholz
hatte bei zwei bisherigen Vernehmungen
eingeräumt dass er sich zu jener Zeit
mit dem Warburg mit Eigentümer oleari
zwei getroffen habe hinsichtlich der
Gesprächsinhalte beriefert sich aber auf
Erinnerungslücken den Verdacht einer
politischen Einflussnahme wie Scholz
stets zurück lass uns noch mal genauer
auf diese cum-ex-geschäfte schauen wir
haben die funktioniert na es ging darum
die Finanzämter zu täuschen die
cumex-geschäfte sind hochkomplex
verschiedene an den Geschäften
Beteiligte Akteure schon sich
Aktienpakete so lange um den
dividendenstichtag hin und her bis der
Finanzbehörde nicht mehr klar war wer
bekommt denn hier jetzt eigentlich noch
alles Kapitalertragsteuer zurück
erstattet und so wurden auch Steuern
zurückgezahlt die vorher nie gezahlt
wurden heute sind solche Geschäfte mit
denen auch die Warburg Bank Millionen
verdiente strafbar zu jener Zeit damals
gab es zu cumex noch keine abschließende
juristische Bewertung vielen Dank für
diese Einordnung
vor anderthalb Jahren ging der Flughafen
Frankfurt Hahn im Hunsrück insolvent nun
wurde für den Airport nach einer
längeren Hängepartie ein neuer Besitzer
gefunden höchst bieten da war der
Immobilienentwickler trivowo alle rund
400 Beschäftigten sollen übernommen
werden zudem will der neue Aigner
gezielt in die flughafeninfrastruktur
investieren wie viel bezahlt wurde ist
nicht bekannt darüber sei Stillschweigen
vereinbart worden
nicht nur auf Ackerflächen sondern auch
in Wäldern nimmt die Zahl der Insekten
deutlich ab das zeigt eine neue Studie
der TU Darmstadt zum insektensterben in
mitteleuropäischen Welt an und 1800
Insektenarten haben die Forschenden
dafür zwischen 2008 und 2017 untersucht
dabei wurde bei 60% ein Rückgang
nachgewiesen laut Studie könne das
Insekten sterben durch eine natürliche
Zusammensetzung der Baumarten und
weniger fellarbeiten abgeschwächt werden
zum Sport und damit zum Viertelfinale
des DFB-Pokals Eintracht Frankfurt traf
am Abend auf Union Berlin und die
Eintracht durfte am Ende feiern
ein Österreicher und ein Schweizer
wollen ins Pokal Halbfinale die Trainer
Oliver Glasner und Urs Fischer aber nur
der Frankfurter Coach kann zunächst
zufrieden sein Kolo myani mit einer
ersten Annäherung Grill rettet stark die
heimannschaft hoch überlegen Mario Götze
mit der Hacke und diese Möglichkeit
lässt sich kolomyalie nicht entgehen das
1:0 in der 11 Minute
die Vorarbeit Weltklasse genauso wie der
Abschluss die starke Union Defensive
kann nur staunen zuschauen ähnliches
Bild keine 90 Sekunden später wieder
Götze auf kolumbiani der Franzose cool
und überlegt sein Doppelpack entscheidet
früh ein Spiel das keine richtige
Spannung aufbaut
2:0 zur Pause Oliver Glasner oben auf
die Berliner von Urs Fischer dagegen
harmlos auch nach dem Wechsel leveling
hier mit der besten Möglichkeit kurz vor
dem Ende die Eintracht steht damit
souverän im DFB-Pokal Halbfinale
und jetzt noch ein fernsehtipp gleich
nach uns ein wichtiges Thema 17
Millionen Menschen weltweit leiden unter
einem chronischen Erschöpfungssyndrom
oft trifft es sehr junge Menschen den
plötzlich jede Energie fehlt 37 Grad
begleitet drei von ihnen gleich das
lohnt sich und dann noch der Hinweis auf
unser heute journal-update gegen
Mitternacht mit Nazan Akademia von uns
allen hier auch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras ein
angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend ja nach
diesen frostigen Temperaturen heute
morgen da werden sich ja viele Fragen wo
bleibt denn die Wärme und ich sag's mal
gleich vorab es gibt jetzt keine
deutlichen Temperatursprünge in den
nächsten Tagen aber bis zum
Osterwochenende steigen die Temperaturen
immerhin wir sehen das hier Beispiel für
Dresden mal über 10 Grad an auch die
Werte in der Nacht die schaffen sich so
langsam bis zum Wochenende aus dem
frostigen Bereich heraus und dann liegen
wir schon eher im Normalbereich für
Mitte April jetzt aktuell ist es bis zu
5 Grad zu kühl tatsächlich für diese
Jahreszeit und das nicht nur bei uns
sondern in ganz Mittel und Osteuropa
denn aus dem Nordosten bringt dieses
hoch die arktische Kaltluft und genau in
dieser Kaltluft hat sich ein kleines
Höhen tief entwickelt mit dem es jetzt
im Osten Deutschlands auch extra etwas
wechselhafter wird wir schauen aber auf
die frostige Nacht mit Ausnahme der
Küste sinken die Temperaturen in den
frostigen Bereich an den alten bis minus
acht am Erdboden des minus zehn Grad
dazu ist es oft klar im Nordosten mit
dichteren Wolken gibt es aber etwas
Regen mit Schnee vermischt der sich dann
zunächst entlang der Oder mal südwärts
ausbreitet morgen gibt es dann zwischen
der Ost und dem RCB viele Wolken und
hier und da mal Regen und etwas Schnee
je weiter wir Richtung Westen und
Richtung Süden schauen desto sonniger
wird der Tag am Rhein erreichen wir auch
mal zweistellige Werte in der Osthälfte
bleibt es mit vier bis acht Grad kühl ja
und die Tage bis Ostern die werden wie
gesagt tagsüber wie auch nachts etwas
milder dafür dann aber auch wieder
wechselhafter das war es von uns das
ganze Wetter Team wünscht einen schönen
Abend